bring you some breaking news this
regards the results of an investigation
into alleged islamophobia within the
conservative party
the investigation has been completed the
report findings are out the
investigation was conducted by the prime
minister's ethics advisor and it says
that there will be no further action
taken against the minister Mark Spencer
after this investigation it has cleared
him of breaching the rules over the
sacking of Tory colleague nisrat ghani
and nizra ghani had claimed that she was
sacked as a minister for being Muslim
the Prime Minister asked his ethics
advisor to take over this investigation
Nusrat ghani made the accusations in
January of last year let's bring in our
political correspondent Rob Powell who
has been following this and has the
results of this report and just remind
us the background first and what the
report has found
yeah so the background to this is that
when Boris Johnson was prime minister he
carried out a mini reshuffle of his uh
ministerial team in February 2020 and
nuzgani who was at that point
um serving as a transport Minister
essentially lost her job known as ghani
was the first female Muslim minister to
speak from the dispatch box in the House
of Commons she was the first female
Muslim Tory MP to be elected
um as well now fast forward two years to
January 2022 last year and she told the
Sunday Times that as part of meetings
around that reshuffle two years earlier
she had been told that her and I'm
quoting here muslimness was raised when
she was removed from that job and that
the her position as a female Muslim
Minister was making some colleagues feel
uncomfortable now shortly after she made
those comments the chief whip at the
time essentially the government's chief
enforcer Mark Spencer identified himself
as the person that nosgani was referring
to he went on to Twitter to do that but
also vehemently denied that he made
those comments and said that he
considered them to be defamatory now
after a various after various inquiries
were commissioned from there it ended up
in the hands of Solari Magnus who is the
current prime minister's ethics advisor
in his report that has gone to Rishi
sunak has just been published along with
Rishi sunak's response and essentially
the conclusion from Sir Laurie Magnus is
that he was unable to definitively say
what actually happened that essentially
Mark Spencer and nuzgani don't disagree
that they met on two occasions that they
provided evidence connected to their
Recollections of those meetings But
ultimately their Recollections differ
quite substantially I can read you part
of the conclusions that Laurie Magnus
came to he says having carefully
reviewed the information submitted to
this investigation it's clear that both
both Ms Garney and Mr Spencer have firm
but very different Recollections of
their two meetings during March 2020 and
both have offered evidence to support
their respective accounts I've been I've
concluded in the light of this
conflicting evidence it's not possible
to determine what transpired in the two
meetings particularly the first meeting
on the 4th of March 2020 which was not
independently witnessed now Solari
Magnus does also say in his findings
that he's found no evidence to suggest
that negative comments about missgany's
faith were either made or had any
resonance in the actual discussions that
took place in the lead-up to that
government reshuffle he did though put
his finger on what he called
shortcomings in the way that nuzganis
complaints and concerns were handled at
the time about some of the statements
that Mark Spencer made on Twitter and
also some of the information that Mark
Spencer as Chief whip gave to the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson at the time now
Rishi sunak replied to Laurie Magnus
essentially because as the prime
minister is the final Arbiter of the
ministerial code so it's he gets this
report and then essentially decides if
he thinks the ministerial code has been
broken and if the person concerned
should stay in their job remember Mark
Spencer is a serving government Minister
albeit an environment Minister now
rather than Chief Whip and in the letter
that Rishi sunak has sent back to Solari
Magnus that's also been published he
said in the absence of clear evidence it
would not be right to take further
action I've spoken to both ministers and
encouraged them to heed your advice to
pull together in the finest tradition of
public service so essentially a
suggestion in there that slurry Magnus
can't find any evidence to back up these
claims from this ghani but equally
um he he's very clear in this that he is
simply not able to come to a definitive
conclusion about what happened and I
think in the absence of any clear
conclusion from Solari Magnus Rishi
sunak has decided that no action should
be taken that Mark Spencer should be
allowed to stay in his ministerial job
we wait to see of course what nasgani
who is also a serving Minister imrishis
United's government has to say about
that and whether she's satisfied about
the conclusion of this inquiry
um and Rob will anything happen now or
is this matter aligned being drawn under
it because missgania has since been
brought back into the government as a
business minister is that right where
are the two involved parties at at the
moment and could anything continue from
this point on
so nuzgarani is a business Minister yes
Mark Spencer is a minister in the
environment Department I believe he's
Foods minister at the moment in terms of
official
um processes and bodies that complaints
could be made to I don't think there is
anywhere else at ansganian Theory could
go I guess this now becomes a question
politically whether nuzgani is happy
that enough has been looked into whether
this matter has been taken seriously
enough at the time when these um
allegations first surfaced she says that
she was worried that essentially the
government wasn't taking these
accusations seriously enough and
remember accusations of islamophobia
within the conservative party
um are nothing new there has been
several of them of them floating around
for quite a while now and several
concerned voices or even within the
party talking about whether the party
has really gripped the issue with the
firmness that it should this will now
clearly be a decision for nuzgarani
about whether she is satisfied with the
outcome of this and whether she is
satisfied with Rishi sunax handling of
this I think the tone of the letter from
Rishi sunak suggests that maybe she is
because Rishi sunak suggests that he has
spoken to both of them and urged them to
um pull together in the finest
traditions of public service but I think
a lot will hinge on what nurse ghani
says now obviously if she is not if she
if she feels so strongly about this
investigation and whether it has gone
far enough in her view she would of
course have the option of resigning her
post from the government albeit
um at the moment that doesn't seem to be
on the table but I think really a lot
hinges on what nuzgarhi says now in
response to this investigation and in
response to what Rishi sunak has done in
him saying that he doesn't think that
any further action is required Rob thank
you rob power the latest there on that
breaking news